en général merci de vous être rendu
disponible pour venir ce matin devant la
commission des lois où nous sommes
heureux bien évidemment de vous
accueillir et si on pouvait fermer la
porte parce que les gens sont bavards
dans les couloirs et ça fait des bruits
afin d'évoquer avec vous le rapport du
Comité des états généraux de la justice
que vous avez remis au Président de la
République au mois de juillet dernier
il est je le crois mais ça peut délicat
pour mettre de le dire puisque j'ai un
peu participé modestement le fruit d'un
travail approfondi qui a été mené entre
le mois d'octobre 2021 et le mois
d'avril 2022 il y a un an d'ailleurs ce
comité était à peu près peut-être même à
date annoncée officiellement et sa
composition officiellement
il faut rappeler d'ailleurs que ce ces
états généraux ont été certes à
l'initiatives du président de la
République mais surtout après une
intervention assez forte je crois de
même la première présidente c'est
Monsieur Mollens également auprès de du
président
venant expliquer la situation critique
dans laquelle se trouvait notre justice
puis de 7000 magistrats ont ensuite
signé une tribune dans la presse en
réaction au suicide dramatique de l'une
de leurs collègues dénonçant
leurs conditions de travail et parfois
même la perte du sens de leur métier ce
qui était évidemment sans précédent
le malaise de notre justice est une
réalité incontestable la perte de
confiance des citoyens dans son action
elle est aussi comme la montrer l'Agora
de la justice que nous avions organisé
au Sénat il y a quasiment un an jour
pour jour à une semaine près
cette réalité le Sénat la mise en
lumière depuis plusieurs années en
faisant d'ailleurs des propositions qui
n'ont pas toujours reçu un avis
favorable de la Chancellerie
ceci très trois principaux rapports que
la commission des lois a produit sur des
dates récentes en 2017 d'abord 50 pour
sauver la justice rapport assez complet
de la Commission à l'époque présidée par
Renaud collegue Philippe Bas en 2019 la
justice prudomale au milieu du gué qui a
été menée en commun avec la commission
des affaires sociales dont Agnès même
canaillé ici présente en a été le
rapporteur et puis en 2021 le droit des
entreprises en difficulté à l'épreuve de
la crise dans notre collègue François
bonhomme et Monsieur tanimag furent
également les rapporteurs d'autres
travaux sont menés régulièrement bien
évidemment et en particulier en période
budgétaire après les avis qui sont
donnés par nos rapporteurs sur les
différentes thématiques liées à la
justice en clair si je peux me permettre
cette expression la commission des lois
et le Sénat depuis longtemps avait quand
même signalé de grandes difficultés et
préconisée un certain nombre de
solutions
il est donc très heureux de retrouver de
nombreux points de convergence parmi les
constats et propositions qui ont été
faites par les États généraux
l'étape nouvelle est maintenant de
s'attacher à la mise en oeuvre de ses
propositions qu'il s'agisse des moyens
de l'organisation et du fonctionnement
de la justice ou des réformes
législatives le Sénat bien évidemment il
veillera et nous tout particulièrement
il informe également il apporte
également que le ministère accepte de
changer de méthode en réformant la
justice de manière systémique au service
du justiciable et d'une meilleure
fonctionnement en évaluant en amont les
conditions pratiques nécessaires à la
réussite de ces réformes et sortent
d'une approche purement normative à cet
égard il nous faudrait ne modifier les
textes que lorsque cela est strictement
nécessaire les juridictions sont
épuisées par des modifications
incessantes des règles et cela vaut tant
pour la loi que pour les textes
réglementaires nous avons pu le
constater lors des différents stages en
juridiction qui ont été faits au sein
des tribunaux judiciaires de Paris de
Lyon de Bordeaux de l'île de Rouen et de
Marseille dans la période du mois de
septembre 2021 à au mois de juin
2022 à peu près 13 13 collègues de la
commission des lois sont allés passer
deux jours dans les jeux élections pour
appréhender les situations et nous
continuerons de le faire cette année
dans des juridictions sans doute de
taille plus modeste monsieur le
Président sauvé
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
comité je vais dans quelques instants
vous laissez la parole pour que vous
puissiez présenter les constats et
recommandations j'ai cru comprendre dans
tous les cas c'est ce que l'on m'a dit
que vous étiez organisé ce ne suis pas
surpris de cela en revanche entre vous
de telle sorte que Madame la premier
présidente
débutera l'intervention suivi de
Monsieur le Procureur Général puis de
monsieur le Président Gavaudan et enfin
de Monsieur sauvé
à l'issue il y aura un jeu de
questions-réponses comme il l'est
d'usage mais je rappelle que nous devons
terminer notre réunion un peu avant 11
heures
donc il est 9h on devrait pouvoir y
arriver sans trop de difficultés
bien je vous remercie de votre attention
je vais vous donner maintenant la parole
madame la première présidente afin que
vous puissiez vous exprimer
merci monsieur le Président comme vous
l'avez indiqué il y a eu beaucoup de
rapports depuis plus de 20 ans
concernant le fonctionnement de la
justice avec un rapport très remarqué
celui de la commission des Lois du Sénat
en 2017 j'allais dire malheureusement
qui n'a pas été suivi de beaucoup
d'effets mais le constat était déjà
sévère l'institution judiciaire est
l'une de celle qui s'est le plus
réformée depuis une trentaine d'années
mais le constat de l'ensemble des
professionnels de justice c'est que la
justice est en très grande difficulté
comme vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur le
Président en juin 2021 mandaté par le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature en
raison de d'attaque incessantes contre
la Justice le procureur général François
Molin c'est moi-même avons rencontré le
président de la République lui avons
présenté l'état de la justice et il a
décidé de lancer des États généraux
qu'il a officiellement lancé le 18
octobre 2021 il y a eu un partage des
tâches entre le ministère de la Justice
les juridictions les avocats et le
comité des États généraux en ce sens que
le ministère de la Justice a lancé une
vaste consultation citoyenne auprès des
citoyens des professionnels
il y a eu 50000 contributions
parallèlement il y a eu des ateliers
citoyens auxquels ont participé les
citoyens qui ont fait un certain nombre
de propositions il y a eu des ateliers
entre les citoyens et des professionnels
de justice parallèlement il y a eu sept
groupes de travail
essentiellement composé de
professionnels de la justice qui en
trois mois ont proposé un certain nombre
de réformes et étaient institués le
comité des États généraux comités
indépendants comme vous l'avez rappelé
présidé par le président sauvé notre
rapport était très fin avril nous
l'avons remis au Président de la
République le 8 juillet et depuis le
garde des sceaux à lancer de vastes
consultation auprès des professionnels
de justice le comité des États généraux
a pris connaissance de l'ensemble des
contributions c'est déplacer en
juridiction pour mesurer la réalité des
juridictions y compris leur d'audience
de comparution immédiate il a été
présent lors d'ateliers notamment de
convergence il a rencontré à plusieurs
reprises les présidents des groupes de
travail il s'est emparé d'un certain
nombre de thèmes qui n'étaient pas dans
la lettre de mission comme la
responsabilité des décideurs publics ou
un thème aussi extrêmement important
comme l'accès aux droits et l'accès à la
citoyenneté comme vous l'avez indiqué
Monsieur le Président
alors que les travaux de du comité
commencé il y a eu cette tribune des
magistrats des greffiers auxquels se
sont joints un certain nombre d'avocats
et les moyens de la justice sont rentrés
en force dans la problématique des États
généraux même s'ils étaient extrêmement
présents le constat du comité est
extrêmement sévère et il y a un certain
nombre de propositions qui sont faites
mais je pense que dans le rapport du
Comité le constat est au moins aussi
important que les propositions parce
qu'il faut changer complètement notre
état d'esprit notre façon de voir et
comme vous l'avez dit arrêtez de
réformer sectoriellement il y a eu un
empilement de réforme depuis une
trentaine d'années beaucoup de
nouveaux de réformes ont été essayés et
ça ne fonctionne pas
il y a des éléments très importants qui
ont été rappelés dans le prologue des
États généraux c'est que la justice est
un service public
on évoque souvent le service public de
la justice mon évoque beaucoup moins
souvent le fait que la justice c'est une
autorité judiciaire qui participe de la
démocratie et de l'État de droit ce que
je n'ai pas indiqué c'est que les
juridictions administratives n'étaient
pas dans le périmètre des États généraux
uniquement les juridictions de l'ordre
judiciaire en tout cas le constat qui a
été porté c'est qu'il y a une crise
majeure de l'institution judiciaire qui
n'a plus les moyens de remplir son rôle
et qui fait l'objet de remise en
question multiple et l'une des
explications et il tient au fait de
politique publique défaillante alors la
justice une justice au bord de la
rupture
nous avons eu beaucoup de statistiques
on voit que les affaires civiles
nouvelles diminuent mais pourtant les
délais s'allongent donc c'est une
question que c'est posée la Cour des
comptes c'est une question que nous nous
sommes posés
dans un contexte où il y a une sur
médiatisation de la justice pénale alors
que la justice civile représente 60% des
contentieux des juridictions de l'ordre
du discerne donc une justice civile en
grande difficulté une justice qui
n'arrive pas à protéger les plus faibles
que sont les mineurs en danger que sont
les personnes sous tutelles dans un
contexte de population
vieillissante une grande difficulté pour
les parquets qui sera évoqués tout à
l'heure une grande difficulté pour le
système pénitentiaire qu'il s'agisse du
milieu fermé ou du milieu ouvert
les justiciables considèrent et ça a été
rappelé dans dans les travaux menés par
le Sénat notamment une grande enquête
qui a été faite il y a à peu près un an
sur la perte de confiance des justiciers
dans la justice ou la paressait que plus
de 50 % des justiciables ne croyaient
plus entre guillemets dans la justice
pour les professionnels c'est une perte
de sens c'est-à-dire une questionnement
même sur le rôle de l'institution
judiciaire
comme je l'ai indiqué il y a eu beaucoup
de réformes il y a des moyens qui ont
été donnés à la justice c'est indéniable
ces dernières années mais en dépit de
tout cela ça ne fonctionne pas et
surtout en dépit d'un engagement
extrêmement fort des magistrats et des
fonctionnaires de justice et le constat
que nous avons fait c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais eu au rarement eu une approche
que l'on a qualifiée de systémique une
approche globale ça a toujours été une
approche sectorielle par exemple on se
rend compte que le l'application des
peines que la prise en charge des peines
par le juge l'application des peines ne
fonctionne pas toujours très bien qu'il
faut attendre un certain temps donc
l'idée ça a été de qu'il y ait une une
procédure qui permette au tribunaux
correctionnel d'aménager les peines à
l'audience en fait ça ne fonctionne pas
très bien pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'il y a trop de dossiers à l'audience
et que les audiences sont tardifs donc
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais cet
exemple montre qu'il y a vraiment des
essais depuis de nombreuses années de
réformer l'institution judiciaire on n'y
arrive pas parce qu'on
examine qu'une toute petite partie du
problème et notamment il y a quelques
années on a voulu déshudiciariser
très rapidement le comité des États
généraux s'est rendu compte que c'était
impossible d'aller plus loin dans la dés
judiciarisation pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'on n'a pas d'outils pilotage
d'outils statistiques digne de ce nom
qui permet de savoir si on désudicia
arrive par exemple les pensions
alimentaires combien ça représente de
dossiers alors qu'on sait que ça
représente 25% des dossiers en matière
civile autre constat que nous avons fait
qui est très important un pilotage
administratif et budgétaire
déficients un sous-investissement
chronique en particulier en ce qui
concerne
l'informatique avec des applications
obsolètes et une inflation de textes
dans notre rapport on a évoqué le nombre
de réformes concernant notamment le code
pénal le code de procédure pénale dès
qu'il y a un problème dans la société il
y a un texte
c'est un empilement de texte et souvent
un problème d'application de la loi dans
le temps au moins en matière civile donc
après ce constat sévère des propositions
ont été faites il y a la question des
moyens que nous avons chiffré
2500 non 1500 magistrats
2500 fonctionnaires des adjoints
administratifs en support aussi des
informations des applications
informatiques et 2500
juristes assistants mais ces moyens ne
suffisent pas parce que il faut
clarifier le rôle de la justice dans la
société l'un des écueils fondamental de
toutes les réformes jusqu'à présent
sauf ça avait été vu un rapport de la
commission des Lois du Sénat c'est à
quoi sert un juge à quoi sert un avocat
à quoi sert un procureur de la
République quel est son quel est
l'Office d'un greffier et on a mesuré
dans le rapport des du comité à quel
point l'office du juge civil avait
changé c'est-à-dire qu'au 19e siècle
c'est un juge qui appliquait et tranchée
et qui appliquait la loi qui tranchait
en bon le juge continue à le faire mais
il y a un office extrêmement important
du juge actuellement qui est un office
protecteur c'est à dire des audiences de
cabinet sans robe et très proche du
citoyen et c'est cette justice là qui
est critiquée par les citoyens comme
étant trop lente peut-être trop cher
également donc la première question
avant toute réforme c'est quel est
l'office du juge quel est l'Office des
professionnels du droit et une fois
qu'on y voit clair on peut procéder à
des réformes des réformes
institutionnelles le rapport du Comité
des États généraux donc ça n'engage que
c'est pas un rapport révolutionnaire en
ce sens qu'on n'a pas proposé un conseil
de justice comme ça existe dans beaucoup
de pays on n'a pas proposé une
séparation du siège et du parquet comme
ça existe dans beaucoup de pays c'est un
rapport pragmatique mais qui est
révolutionnaire par son approche qui est
une approche d'ensemble donc pas de
conseils de justice proposé pour
administrer les biens de la justice mais
une évolution du rôle du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature une
réarticulation de
la responsabilité politique
responsabilité pénale une augmentation
des ressources de la justice qui est
absolument indispensable l'équipe autour
du magistrat on en parle beaucoup il y a
eu un rapport déposé par Madame
Dominique leting qui était membre du
Conseil constitutionnel sur l'équipe
autour du magistrat mais qui est que
l'un des aspects de la réforme c'est pas
tout c'est pas parce qu'il y aura une
équipe autour du magistrat que
l'ensemble des problèmes de la justice
sera solutionné des propositions sur le
recrutement dans la magistrature des
propositions sur l'informatique dont il
est urgent de faire évoluer les systèmes
faire évoluer les organisations
territoriales nous avons pas été
partisans de supprimer des juridictions
c'est pas du tout dans cet esprit là on
croit beaucoup à la justice de proximité
en même temps à la spécialisation des
contentieux l'idée c'était plutôt de
faire évoluer les organisations d'un
point de vue budgétaire le rapport du
Sénat avait dit en 2017 il y a eu un
rapport également de l'accord des
comptes un point également important
c'est l'éducation au droit et la
politique d'accès aux droits nous avons
mesuré à quel point dans les
établissements scolaires il y a une
éducation à la citoyenneté qui est
prévue mais nous avons mesuré c'est que
dans les faits pour des raisons
conjoncturelles cette éducation n'est
pas forcément très efficiente il y a un
certain nombre de propositions qui sont
faites et aussi une proposition très
importante que l'institution judiciaire
communique mieux nous avons la culture
de l'obligation de réserve et
collectivement nous communiquons assez
mal sur ce que nous faisons
peut-être pour terminer mon intervention
un focus sur la justice civile ce qui
est marquant dans l'institution
judiciaire c'est qu'il y a très peu
d'observateurs capables d'observer sur
une période de 30 ans les grandes
évolutions une grande évolution il y a
30 ans il y avait pratiquement que des
magistrats civilistes actuellement il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de magistrats
pénalistes et de moins en moins de
magistrats civilistes dans un contexte
où il y a eu un large accès de la
justice à la justice du quotidien donc
beaucoup de contentieux
numériquement important qu'on peut
qualifier aussi de contentieux de masse
mais qui humainement sont très complexes
à gérer c'est ce que j'évoquais ce sont
les audiences de cabinet ce qui fait que
l'aspect spécialisation des magistrats
pour les matières complexes et de moins
en moins importants les magistrats étant
très pris par la justice du quotidien
sauf à la cour de Paris essentiellement
un peu à Versailles et sauf à la Cour de
cassation la justice civile dans les
juridictions de première instance
représente 60% du contentieux en cours
d'appel 75 à 80 % et dans ces 75 et le
dans ces 75 à 80 % le comptant sur
social en cours d'appel représente la
moitié du contentieux avec un très fort
taux d'appel des conseils des
prud'hommes la justice c'est civile
c'est lentement dégradé depuis une
quinzaine d'années en raison de
multiples facteurs il y a eu un
excellent rapport d'un inspection
générale de la justice un
malheureusement qui n'a pas été rendu
public sur l'attractivité des fonctions
civiles qui exposent l'ensemble de la
problématique les causes sont multiples
à une pénalisation de la société
les le fait que a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de contentieux
numériquement important que devait
traiter les juridictions dans un
contexte de sous dotation importante de
la justice l'ensemble de ces facteurs
comme conséquence il y a 30 ans
pratiquement toutes les audiences
étaient collégiales en première instance
et actuellement c'est essentiellement du
juge unique et des contenus de la carte
judiciaire il y a beaucoup de petites
juridictions de petites structures ou
des jeunes magistrats président
l'audience civile ou statue seul en
matière civile donc le comité des États
généraux à proposer de redonner la
priorité à la première instance ce qui
n'est plus le cas actuellement avec un
taux d'appel qui peut varier de 14 à 60
70 % en matière pénale qui est une vraie
politique publique civile à mettre en
place on parle beaucoup de la politique
pénale mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'un
garde des sceaux entendu par les
commissions des lois sur la politique
civile menée au ministère de la Justice
un élément également important
développer les modes alternatives de
règlement des différents les modes
alternatifs ça n'est pas un piset pour
traiter les stocks dans les juridictions
c'est une vraie politique et sortir de
cette culture du conflit que nous avons
souvent en France et nous avons pas
cette démarche première de la
conciliation et de la médiation pour
résumer ce rapport c'est
d'avoir une vision globale quand on
réforme de se poser les questions sur
quel est l'Office d'un juge d'un
procureur d'un avocat de ne plus
réformer par secteur et de changer
totalement d'état d'esprit et si on ne
le fait pas moi enfin je ne ça n'engage
que moi ce que je vais dire c'est que la
crise était déjà importante il y a 10
ans et elle ne fait que s'aggraver et
plus ça continuera plus la crise
s'aggravera si on n'a pas cette idée
globale de réforme de l'institution il y
a beaucoup de parties prenantes il y a
le gouvernement il y a le Parlement il y
a les professionnels du droit les
citoyens et ce qui est très compliqué
c'est que tout le monde ensemble aille
dans la même direction merci Madame
passer la parole à Monsieur Mollens vous
indiquer quand même que notre audition
est retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat pour chacun le sache
et qu'elle s'inscrit aussi dans la
préparation du débat sur la justice que
nous aurons lui qui aura lieu en
sciences publiques le 4 octobre prochain
donc on est aussi dans cette logique
Monsieur le Procureur général
merci Monsieur Président je m'inscris
sans aucune réserve dans ce que vient de
vous dire
Madame à Reims en préambule je voudrais
peut-être souligner d'ailleurs sous
votre contrôle puisque vous en faisiez
partie que l'exercice n'allait pas de
soi je pense que ça a été un exercice de
qualité un exercice riche un exercice
qui allait pas de soi parce qu'il y
avait quand même un certain nombre de
personnalités très différentes au sein
du comité des hauts fonctionnaires des
magistrats des personnalités politiques
des avocats un ambassadeur des
professeurs
c'était pas évident et pour autant je
pense qu'on a toujours assisté à des
qualités il y a jamais eu contrairement
à ce que j'ai pu lire un jour dans un
périodique de querelle de chiffonniers
c'est totalement faux et la preuve en
est que comme toujours dans ce genre de
de travail il y a des sujets plus ou
moins clivants tout le monde aura pu
noter que il y a des sujets qui ont pu
faire il y a des sujets qui ont donné
lieu à des opinions majoritaires
minoritaires il y a jamais eu c'est un
exemple à mon avis qui est assez fort
d'expression d'opinions dissidentes par
rapport à certaines conclusions ce qui
montre quand même un socle minimal de
consensus sur la fois la méthode et puis
le résultat auquel on est parvenu alors
je vais vous parler moi très rapidement
de la procédure pénale qui n'est pas je
dis les choses très franchement le sujet
j'allais dire le plus riche en termes de
proposition formulée mais ça s'explique
très bien je vais essayer de vous dire
pourquoi
on ne peut je pense lire le les
conclusions du rapport du Comité qu'à la
lumière des conclusions du groupe de
travail procédure pénale dont il faut
dire que sans vouloir reprendre toutes
les propositions qu'il avait pu formuler
il s'était prononcé lui aussi dans sa
majorité pour le maintien du jeu
instruction avec toutefois une
proposition
assez innovante qui consistait à créer
un nouveau cadre d'enquête à travers une
comparution au fait personnes d'enquête
complémentaires qui aurait permis au
parquet en cours d'enquête de faire
déférer la personne devant lui de lui
notifier un certain nombre de charges de
l'interroger et puis après de poursuivre
l'enquête sur le contrôle d'un juge il y
avait aussi un certain nombre de
propositions pour rénover les délais
d'instruction pour parachever le
contrats pour améliorer la qualité de la
distillation exemple passer la durée de
la flagrance à 15 jours au lieu de 8
jours et puis enfin nouvelle mesure
phare dans l'évolution des pouvoirs
conférés au parquet c'était la création
d'une mesure transactionnelle qui aurait
permis avec l'accord de la personne
concernée de
de décider de mettre en oeuvre des
mesures des mesures transactionnelles
avec notamment des amendes composition
qui aurait pu donc être mis en oeuvre
avec la corde de la personne poursuivie
et en cas contraire de revenir dans les
modes classiques d'orientation des
poursuites
le comité donc c'est c'est donc prononcé
par rapport à tout ça et sans aller dans
le détail de certaines des mesures qui
avaient été proposées par le groupe de
travail
a voulu attacher son proclamer son
attachement de choses vous noterez que
les polémiques sur la réforme la police
judiciaire n'avait pas encore commencé
lorsqu'on a travaillé la première
accroche de la Procure pénale dans notre
rapport a consisté à marquer
l'attachement du comité au respect du
principe de la direction de la police
judiciaire par les magistrats
c'est quelque chose qui prend plus
d'actualité depuis quelques semaines
c'est effectivement un principe va
falloir constitutionnelle donc c'était
peut-être effectivement important de le
rappeler le comité a surtout voulu
assumer une différence forte par rapport
à ce qui avait été dans le groupe de
travail c'est autour de cette notion de
simplification
il a pris à son compte le fait que la
complexification à laquelle on existe
depuis 20 ans dans la procédure pénale
résulte d'abord et en partie d'un
renforcement de la garantie des droits
et que si bien sûr l'architecture et la
lisibilité du code de procure pénal
peuvent et doivent être améliorées la
simplification ne peut pas déboucher sur
un affaiblissement de ces garanties et
qu'en particulier la présomption
d'innocence le droit procès équitable le
délai raisonnable les droits de la
défense ne pourrait pas se trouver
corner ou diminuer au prétexte d'une de
l'année d'une nécessaire simplification
du code de procédure pénale c'est toutes
les limites effectivement de cette
température de de simplification
le groupe de travail
le comité a donc estimé c'est une des
grandes idées c'est ce qui explique
peut-être que sous le contrôle de mes
collègues on est plus pas pu aller trop
trop loin dans la réflexion le comité a
estimé que
il y avait
il était aujourd'hui indispensable de
refendre le code de procédure pénale je
dis bien refondre c'est le mot qu'on
employé
c'est quelque chose je pense qui va
au-delà de la simple dimension
codification simplification
même si on a estimé qu'une simple
reconndification en droit constant
constituerait à elle seule un chantier
pluriel on a donc on sait donc tout
s'accorder sur le fait que ce code était
frapper aujourd'hui par son inadéquation
qu'il était devenu lisible et peu
praticable on a évoqué notamment
l'évolution entre 2008-2022 14 ans un
code qui passe de 1700 articles à 2400
donc 700 articles de plus en 14 ans ce
qui est quand même considérable donc peu
de lisibilité
problème de cohérence et nécessité d'une
grande stabilité qui conduit en réalité
là aussi c'est quelque chose qui revient
souvent dans les travaux du comité qui
conduit à la nécessité de d'inscrire de
s'inscrire dans une démarche systémique
qui s'attache au fond des choses avec
une vision globale et qui amène à
s'inscrire dans une logique de long
terme compte tenu des délais probables
de réécriture c'est ce que nous avons
nous avons repris à notre compte et
c'est un avis du groupe de travail que
le comité a donc entièrement partagé
donc on a délibéré sur un certain nombre
de questions essentielles que devrait
trancher le nouveau code de procure
pénale alors la première qui a donné
lieu à une opinion majoritaire c'est le
du jeu instruction
je pense qu'on a tous eu conscience il y
a eu d'ailleurs des opinions là-dessus
que on vit dans un paysage qui est quand
même assez particulier puisqu'il y a
trois cadres d'enquêtes qui et
d'investigation qui coexistent avec
l'enquête préliminaire l'enquête en
flagrant c'est l'instruction avec
97% des dossiers qui sont traités par le
parquet une instruction qui ne rassemble
plus que 3% des affaires et donc un
cadre j'allais dire juridique dans
lequel dans lequel on s'inscrit et qui
voit que les droits des gens et les
procédures ne sont pas identiques dans
chacun de ces trois cadres d'enquêtes on
est malgré tout c'est pas uneanimité
mais c'est une c'est une majorité on a
manifesté notre attachement à l'office
du jeu d'instruction dont on a voulu
souhaiter dont on a voulu affirmer
souligner l'expertise la réactivité et
l'efficacité
particulièrement dans les domaines de du
des affaires criminelles de la grande
criminalité
du terrorisme et de la criminalité cyber
et de la criminalité financière
le il nous a aussi
il nous a aussi paru évident que le
[Musique]
la disparition du jeu instruction serait
d'autant plus difficile à mettre en
œuvre
au profit finalement d'un ministère
public donc tout le monde s'accorde à
reconnaître que ces garanties
statutaires sont insuffisantes et ça
serait effectivement problématique de
remplacer l'Office d'un juge par un
parquetier qui ne bénéficient pas
effectivement des mêmes du même statut
donc là aussi je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est frappait du bon sens et
qui donc s'est traduit par une opinion
majoritaire au sein du comité le comité
en réalité a voulu défendre on oppose
toujours le système accusatoire au
système inquisitoire on est en France
dans un système mixte qui finalement
emprunt à la fois au modèle inquisitoire
au modèle accusatoire on a voulu
défendre ce modèle mixte qui nous paraît
garantir une part importante du
contradictoire dans la phase
préparatoire procès pénale et qui nous
paraît être celui aussi qui garantit le
mieux j'allais dire les qualités
l'égalité des droits et l'accès à la
justice contrairement à d'autres
systèmes je pense notamment au système
américain ou l'égalité est loin d'être
identique on a estimé dans le cadre de
ce maintien du jus d'instruction que
n'était pas souhaitable la création de
la nouvelle procédure que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure qui était souhaité par
le groupe de travail donc créé un
nouveau cadre d'enquête avec une enquête
complémentaire on a estimé que ça
risquait de complexifier encore
davantage les cadres juridiques
existants et que pour cette raison ça
n'était donc pas souhaitable on a aussi
estimé que contenu du fonctionnement de
la justice on ne pouvait pas se priver
aujourd'hui d'une réflexion de fond sur
la question de la tenue des audiences de
comparution immédiates qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs dans les mécanismes qui
sont aussi pour qui explique aussi au
moins en partie la surpopulation
pénitentiaire à travers l'augmentation
des pannes de prison qui sont données
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
au travers des des faux procès et des
procès d'intention qu'on entend souvent
sur l'axisme de la justice
les pannes de prison dans leur moyenne
ont augmenté de quasiment deux mois dans
l'espace de quelques années donc là
aussi ça tord le coup
qui reproche là pour autant il y a un
vrai sujet sur ces audiences de
comparution immédiates à travers
effectivement le recours à des postures
de plus en plus de plus en plus rapide
et à des audiences dont un certain
nombre d'acteurs ont souligné le
caractère tardif et les mauvaises
conditions qui dans lesquelles
effectivement la justice pénale pouvait
être amenée à fonctionner en fonctionner
aujourd'hui on a aussi souhaité une
réflexion sur le déroulement de
l'audience devant le tribunal criminel
départemental Dans le cadre de la
réécriture du code de procure pénal ça
prend aussi du sens puis
qu'effectivement on était sur un schéma
d'expérimentation qui a été finalement
clos avant de venir au terme à
l'expérimentation et qui s'est traduit
par la généralisation donc je pense que
cette appréciation prend un certain
relief au regard effectivement de la
précipitation
en tout cas l'accélération du processus
qui a été choisi par le législateur
enfin ça aussi c'est quelque chose
d'assez fort le comité je crois
d'ailleurs sous le contrôle de mes
collègues je crois il y a une quasiment
une unanimité là-dessus on n'a pas
estimé souhaitable d'aller encore plus
loin dans les pouvoirs donné au parquet
on trouve que au regard des équilibres
institutionnels auxquels on arrive
aujourd'hui des garanties statutaires du
ministère public il ne nous a pas paru
opportun et souhaitable d'aller encore
plus loin et d'aller jusqu'à conférer la
décision à la mise en oeuvre par le
ministère public d'une mesure de l'ordre
transactionnel on pense que ça ne
pourrait que venir brouiller encore
davantage le paysage institutionnel et
brouillé encore davantage l'office du
parquet l'office du juge
dernière chose que je soulignerai et en
ayant encore une fois conscience et
limite mais elle s'explique très bien on
a pas su en réalité tout comme
d'ailleurs le groupe de travail résoudre
le choix qui pouvait s'opérer entre un
certain nombre de modèles et notamment
un certain nombre de cadres d'enquêtes
et notamment une grande question qui
s'est posée à la fois au groupe au
comité est-ce qu'il faut
fusionner les cadres d'enquête bon il y
a bien sûr le maintien ou la suppression
que je vais instruction mais faut-il ou
pas fusionner les cadres d'enquête de la
flagrance et de l'enquête préliminaire
et si on les fusionne dans quel sens
faut-il aller faut-il aller vers la
généralisation du cadre de l'enquête
préliminaire ou au contraire ce que
souhaite certains
où faut-il au contraire aller ce que
souhaite d'autres comme notamment le
directeur général à la police nationale
lorsqu'on l'a entendu fusionner pour que
on est un seul cadre qui serait
l'enquête de
on n'a pas
pu et souhaiter répondre à cette
question parce que on se rend compte que
quand on pousse les feux de la réflexion
on n'a pas en réalité aujourd'hui
d'éléments suffisants en termes d'étude
d'impact sur les conséquences précises
et profondes que pourrait comporter le
choix d'une solution ou de l'autre donc
on a estimé et ça aussi c'est pas pour
le comité d'une façon de se défausser
c'est au contraire j'allais dire une
preuve du sérieux dans lequel il du
sérieux de sa réflexion le comité a
estimé qu'il était absolument
aujourd'hui indispensable avant toute
réécriture du code de procure pénal
d'avoir mis en oeuvre par le ministère
de la Justice une étude d'impact qui
soit extrêmement fouillée et approfondi
pour qu'on mesure bien les conséquences
de ses choix parce que les questions
paraissent faciles on s'aperçoit en
réalité que le diable se niche
véritablement dans les détails et que
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça en a
l'air donc ça nous effectivement un
exercice préalable qui doit venir
intervenir avant toute réflexion de fond
sur effectivement
auquel pourrait conduire une réécriture
voilà je suis pas exhaustif dans tout ce
que ce que j'ai dit j'ai essayé de vous
résumer l'ensemble effectivement des des
réflexions sur un plan général du code
je suis pas rentré dans le détail il y a
aussi je vais pas aborder un sérum de
choses qui sont dans le groupe de
travail procure pénal qui sont en
réalité quand on regarde bien mais ça je
pense que la commission des lois le sait
beaucoup mieux que moi on retrouve un
salon de mesure que certains acteurs
avaient essayé de mettre dans la loi
2019 et qui sont restés à la porte
effectivement qui n'ont pas été repris
par les parlementaires donc je pense que
il y a des choses que certains ont voulu
essayer de remettre dans le dans le dans
la seringue
je veux pas perdre de temps à revenir
sur ces choses que tout le monde connaît
de dont vous avez déjà eu l'occasion de
parler je vous remercie de votre
attention
la parole à mettre gavaudon qui est le
président du Conseil National des
Barreaux merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames messieurs
quelques éléments simplement sans
rallonger là je souscris à ce qui a été
dit par Madame la première présidente et
Monsieur le Procureur général il y a
rien à dire je voudrais faire trois
observations la première sur le contexte
et l'état d'esprit qui a été rappelé par
Madame la première présidente dans
laquelle c'est sont inscrits ces états
généraux et le travail effectué par le
Comité des États généraux qui est un
comité totalement indépendant et nous
avons tenu à cette indépendance l'état
d'esprit qui a mené nos travaux et qui
finalement a non seulement amené une
travaux mais c'est celui que nous avons
recueilli des personnes que nous avons
entendues et même des groupes de travail
est assez à contre-courant de ce qui ce
qui s'est fait jusqu'à présent dans le
cas la réforme de la justice je le
souvenir il y a pas si longtemps pour la
réforme qui avait été menée par la
beloubet dans cette même salle sur un
certain nombre d'auditions auprès de
votre commission à qui viennent
apprendre à rien de ce que nous
souffrions d'une vision utilitariste du
système judiciaire des judiciarisation
conciliation obligatoire par voie de
l'égaltech payantes faisant fille à la
fois de la fracture numérique et puis de
l'incapacité du citoyen à connaître
comment on saisit éventuellement une
juridiction voire un médiateur on
craignait les problématiques de cartes
judiciaire de suppression juridiction
qu'on voulait spécialiser de manière
départementale ce qui pouvait faire
craindre l'assèchement d'un certain
nombre de matières dans certaines
juridictions et donc leur dévitalisation
totale
le juge stackanoviste l'avocat renvoyé
dans ses dans ses cordes de
d'auxiliaires de justice qui doit se
plier à une procédure civile de plus en
plus compliquée
bref nous étions dans l'utilitarisme les
réflexions les travaux à partir
d'ailleurs de ce qui a été
présenté au président de la République
par le madame la Présidente la première
présidente de Monsieur broker générale
était tout autre
un constat de quasi épuisement qui a été
admis qui a été accepté un manque de
moyens c'est pas simplement sur ce point
que nous avons travaillé mais il fallait
que ce constat soit dressé une détresse
des une des 13 des magistrats qui
tiennent et des personnels de grève et
greffiers qui tiennent l'institution
judiciaire et en miroir aussi la
souffrance qui a été exprimée et qui a
pu valablement s'exprimer par les
professionnels du droit et en premier
les avocats qui effectivement sont elles
eux aussi
potentiellement les victimes de cette de
cette dégradation
l'état d'esprit aussi était intéressant
parce que pour la première fois du côté
de la magistrature je crois que c'est
important de le dire à votre à votre
commission il y a eu la reconnaissance
de cette difficulté pas simplement des
juges de terrain pardon mais aussi des
chefs de juridiction qui connaissent
bien au théâtre c'est parce que je veux
dire qui ont admis effectivement qui a
au bout d'un moment n'arrivait plus à on
aurait pu obtenir et qu'il fallait un
peu de souplesse un peu de liberté un
peu de moyens un peu de possibilité de
réorganiser de réorganiser les choses ça
a été admis et je crois que c'est un
point très important et puis aussi la
conviction que tout cela se fait non pas
pour l'institution judiciaire non pas
pour l'autorité judiciaire on a beaucoup
les uns et les autres insisté sur le
fait qu'il s'agissait bien d'une
autorité et qui si elle est malmenée à
des impacts sur la respiration de la
démocratie vous l'avez rappelé madame ma
première présidente mais c'est un point
important une justice malmenée c'est une
justice qui n'est plus indépendante un
juge qui ne peut pas trancher parce
qu'il a pas les moyens en matière civile
comme en matière pénale c'est une
justice qui n'a plus d'indépendance tout
ça a été tout ça a été évoqué et c'était
important parce que le cœur doit
préoccupations c'est la fin de mon
premier point c'était comme ça l'est
pour vous je pense le justicierbe et les
présentations qui sont faites sont assez
techniques parce que nous sommes
finalement des techniciens mais ce qui a
mené nos débats essentiellement c'est
vraiment le citoyen et la République sur
la sur la cet état d'esprit a permis de
libérer un certain nombre de sujets en
matière de de procédure civile je pense
que mais là aussi c'est pas tellement
nouveau mais ça a été finalement acté il
faut s'intéresser la justice civile il
faut lui donner le moyen il faut
s'intéresser au juge il faut avoir on a
beaucoup travaillé sur ces questions là
d'aspect sociologiques c'est-à-dire
quels sont les profils des magistrats
qui sortent de l'école nationale de la
magistrature quels sont les profils des
magistrats qui vont être intégrés dans
la magistrature les jeunes sont-ils
encore en
ont-ils le souhait ou l'énergie de
travailler et de tenir des audiences
correctionnelles jusqu'à 23 heures tout
ça ce sont des éléments qui ont été
actés entendus et sur lequel on a nous
avons nous avons nous avons avancé
réforme de la procédure civile
éventuellement réforme de la procédure
d'appel qui peut se faire par voie
réglementaire nous l'avons évoqué il y a
eu consensus aussi sur ces questions là
non pas pour libérer la possibilité des
avocats de multiplier les actes de
procédure mais parce que effectivement
s'aperçoit que les choses trappes
procédurales ne permettent pas de gagner
du temps ou d'avancer repositionner le
magistrat redonner de la valeur au juge
de première instance toutes choses qu'il
méritait d'être qui méritait d'être dit
et puis aussi en tout cas pour la
profession d'avocat rappeler que pour
nous l'office du juge est très important
et qu'il y avoir des réflexions sur le
fils du juge mais que nous préférons
toujours que ce soit le juge qui est au
total décide pas simplement tranche le
litige mais aussi soit le maître de
l'organisation judiciaire et je crois
que c'était très important parce que
très nouveau vous avez évoqué madame la
première présidente la question des mots
d'alternatifs de règlement des
différents ou des litiges c'est vrai que
on a admis que ce n'était pas
la panacée et que les moles de règlement
des différents ne sont pas là pour
éviter la saisine du juge ils sont là
pour accompagner le justiciable et
d'ailleurs nous essayons dans la
profession d'avocate de désormais éviter
le terme qui va encore changer de modèle
alternatif dragon est différent pour
dire des modes de règlement de
différents il faut que nous changions
nous-mêmes nos pratiques notre vision
des choses c'est pas alternatif c'est à
côté de la saisine de la saisine du juge
sur la procédure pénale je ne rajoute
pas ce qui était très important aussi
dans nos débats et c'est important de le
dire ici dans cette commission des lois
très attachées aux libertés publiques
individuelles il n'a jamais été question
et pour nous c'était très important dans
deux départs sur le juge d'instruction
donc dos débats sur le sur la sur les
sur la pro sur l'enquête dans nos débat
sur une éventuelle réforme du Code de
Procédure c'est mal pénal dans nos
débats sur les traitements des notamment
des matières correctionnelles ce qui
était très important c'était le citoyen
le présumé innocent les droits de la
défense et sous l'autorité judiciaire et
pas par exemple son autorité
administrative nous avons aujourd'hui
peut-être de nous dirions différemment
mais nous avons aussi évoqué la place du
parquet mais aussi la place de la police
administrative et je confirme ce que
vient de dire le poker général nous
n'avions pas exprimé nous l'aurions
exprimé différemment mais en tout cas
nous sommes tous très attachés c'est un
consensus à ce que la police judiciaire
soit effectivement rattachée au
magistrat parce que ce sont eux qui sont
d'abord et avant tout les garants de
liberté individuelle
merci monsieur le Président avant de
donner la parole au président Sauvet je
voudrais quand même rappeler pour avoir
en tête un chiffre qui date de 2019 la
justice civile c'est plus de 2 millions
200000 décisions pour l'année 2019 la
justice pénale c'est un peu plus de 800
pour distinguer pour bien peser les
choses et l'opinion publique se forme
sur la justice pénale mais c'est
important mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel
monsieur le Président sauvé vous avez la
parole
je voudrais d'abord souligner que je
suis complètement d'accord avec mes
collègues qui se sont exprimés
auparavant et qui ne se sont pas
exprimés à titre personnel mais qui ont
bien rendu compte du rapport je me
contenterai pour éviter des redites de
quelques notations
d'abord sur la crise de la justice
il faut bien voir que nous sommes dans
notre pays confronté à une double crise
une crise universelle et une crise
nationale la crise universelle c'est la
crise de l'autorité judiciaire de ce
pouvoir
public constitutionnel qui est
inséparable de la démocratie et de
l'État de droit tout ceci est lié au
rôle croissant du juge dans nos sociétés
le juge appliqué la loi
disons jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle il
est devenu l'interprète de la loi
désormais il est juge de la loi
notamment au travers du contrôle de
conventionalité nous savons tous
qu'aujourd'hui
aucune décision de politique publique ne
peut être prise sans considération de la
manière dont un juge national ou
européen appréciera cette décision c'est
une expérience quotidienne que nous
faisons y compris par exemple sur la
possibilité de réformer des retraites
par la voie de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour prendre le
dernier exemple le juge en fait
co-construit le droit dans tous les pays
et ceci introduit une rupture dans le
fonctionnement des pouvoirs publics
traduit par une judiciarisation de la
vie publique en France et donc tous les
états et ceci
crée des turbulences et des tensions
dans la totalité des pays je n'en
connais qu'un seul qui souhaite épargner
par ces turbulences c'est l'Allemagne
mais elle a fait une expérience
historique au 20e siècle qui met
l'institution judiciaire tout à fait à
part et incontesté crise de l'autorité
judiciaire crise du service public de la
justice alors tout a été dit mais je
voudrais quand même souligner qu'elle
est très paradoxale puisque la demande
de justice
au cours de la dernière décennie
n'a pas augmenté substantiellement mais
que les délais et les stocks ont
augmenté donc différentes raisons qui
sont notamment
lié à la complexification du droit et la
difficulté particulière des affaires
voilà ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que
l'allongement des Dédé nous le
constatons dans le champ civil dans le
champ pénal dans le champ de la justice
de protection
qui d'une certaine manière dysfonctionne
également nous avons un retard dans
l'exécution des décisions de la justice
pénale et de protection tous ces points
sont majeurs et je voulais les souligner
et puis il y a un malaise sur une
justice qui est peu compréhensible et
accessible en ce qui concerne le
diagnostic je vais tout à fait dans le
sens de ce qu'elle dit la première
présidente
nous avons nommé une question qui a été
soigneusement dissimulé je crois par le
pouvoir exécutif au cours des deux
dernières décennies pas dans les
rapports parlementaires c'est le déficit
des moyens
c'est insuffisance a été nié
officiellement mais en fait avouer au
travers des tentatives de
dégudiciarisation des 20 dernières
années
le problème qui se pose n'est pas
seulement celui des moyens c'est aussi
celui de l'incapacité à penser la
justice de manière systémique et à la
gérer de manière rationnelle
les réformes de la justice souvent
utile dans leur inspiration ont trop
consistés dans un égrenage de mesure
ponctuelles et au fond on a appliqué
quelques rustines un dispositif qui
s'enfonçait petit à petit
les réformes ont aussi été largement
déconnectés des conditions de leur
application
le ministère de la Justice et le temple
du législantisme et j'ai pu constater
que 40 ans après
les 7 années que j'ai passé à la
Chancellerie dans les années 80 en
réalité rien n'avait changé
il y a également sur le plan de la
gestion de la justice des problèmes des
problèmes majeurs je parle bien sûr
d'une organisation déconcentrée qui
n'est qui n'est pas lisible qui n'est
pas compréhensible mais aussi de
l'insuffisance du management il n'y a
pas de pilotage cohérent de
l'institution il n'y a pas de gestion
des ressources humaines dignes de ce nom
et il faut porter remède à cette
situation
alors quant à la réforme qui est
proposée par le comité quant aux réforme
qui sont proposés par le comité il faut
être au clair sur le positionnement de
la justice dans la société et par
rapport aux autres pouvoirs publics
comme l'a dit auparavant la première
présidente nous ne proposons pas de
conseils de justice ni de séparation
entre le siège et le parquet nous ne
proposons pas non plus de remettre en
cause le principe de la gestion
administrative et financière de la
justice par le gouvernement sous le
contrôle du Parlement mais il y a des
réformes importantes à mener notamment
sur le statut du parquet
cette réforme qui a été envisagée et
même préparé en 2000 moi j'ai soumis au
président de la République un décret de
convocation du Congrès et quelques
semaines ensuite soumettre un deuxième
décret de démontage du Congrès c'est la
seule fois dans l'histoire de la
République qu'un tel acte a été pris
voilà nous proposons aussi de revoir un
certain nombre
d'équilibre au sein du CSM et en
particulier de la commission
d'avancement il faut aussi c'est un
sujet
un peu périphérique mais très sensible
revoir la responsabilité pénale des
décideurs publics en particulier des
membres du gouvernement il faut
supprimer l'accord de justice de la
République et aménager les règles de
fond de la responsabilité pénale quand
les actes mis en cause découlent
directement de la mise en oeuvre par les
ministres et leurs collaborateurs de la
politique du gouvernement
je n'insiste pas sur le renforcement de
la première instance la première
présidente a dit tout ce qui était
nécessaire c'est un point fondamental du
rapport je voudrais
souligner de manière plus technique le
besoin de professionnels la gestion des
ressources humaines il faut que ces
ressources soient gérées et qu'elle soit
mieux répartie on introduisant une
vision de moyens et long terme avec des
référentiels d'activités il faut aussi
diversifier le recrutement et ouvrir la
formation des magistrats il faut évaluer
et refonder l'évaluation des chefs de
juridiction évaluer aussi les premiers
présidents de cour d'appel et des
magistrats de la Cour de cassation qui
ne le sont pas
bien sûr la stratégie numérique doit
être refondu il faut vraiment
refonder la maîtrise d'ouvrages de ces
applications et renforcer la place du
numérique dans la conception des
réformes et aussi et aussi dans les
directions métiers du ministère de la
Justice la direction des affaires
civiles la direction des affaires
criminelles et pas seulement
l'administration pénitentiaire et la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse par
ailleurs des réformes sectorielles sont
indispensables je ne reviens pas sur la
nécessité de mettre en place une
véritable politique publique de la
justice civile c'est un point
fondamental
civile qui était la première branche de
la justice la plus noble est aujourd'hui
totalement sinistre
dans ce contexte là j'ai oublié sur les
réformes statutaires il est
indispensable de séparer le grade et
l'enclos notamment pour permettre de
renforcer la première instance avec des
magistrats seniors des magistrats capés
expérimentés
il faut alors pour la justice économique
et sociale nous en avons peu parlé mais
nous avons tout un ensemble de
propositions sur la justice du travail
des conseils de prud'hommes et la
justice commerciale avec
l'expérimentation de tribulots des
affaires économiques et aussi
l'expérimentation de la participation
des parties au financement de la justice
dans le cadre de la justice économique
voilà sur la procédure pénale le
procureur général à tout dit et je ne
saurai mieux m'exprimer que lui je
voudrais sur les questions
pénitentielles
rappelez que nous avons pris position
peut-être on jugera notre rapport banal
sur le sens de la peine c'est un point
qui nous est apparu important la peine a
pour objet de sanctionner des
comportements déviants elle a aussi pour
objet de préparer la réinsertion des
condamnés et elle a pour objet de
réduire le risque de récidive dans ce
contexte nous ne proposons pas
d'enchaîner les programmes de
construction d'établissements
pénitentiaires au-delà
ceux qui ont été décidées et qui sont en
cours nous proposons de limiter de
manière volontariste le recours aux
courtepen de renforcer
substantiellement les moyens du milieu
ouvert on évoque la possibilité de créer
une agence du milieu ouvert nous
proposons également pour mieux articuler
le prononcer des peines et leur
exécution de faire revenir les services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et probation
dans les juridictions pour personnaliser
les peines et permettre leur aménagement
effectifs à binicio et enfin nous
proposons pour éviter des condamnations
à répétition pour traitement inhumains
et dégradant de mettre en place un
dispositif de régulation de la
population carcérale qui
ne soit pas un humérus clausus pur et
simple voilà quelques-unes des
perspectives que nous mettons sur la
table
merci monsieur le Président merci à
chacun et chacune à vous madame la
Présidente et à vous messieurs des
propos tenus on va ouvrir le débat et je
propose de la parole la madame Dominique
Verrien qui est rapporteur d'ailleurs
avec Madame canaillé du budget de la
justice
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci
à vous quatre de cette présentation
à la fois synthétique mais quasi
exhaustive de votre rapport
qui était effectivement très intéressant
et qui reprend à certains nombre de
choses comme vous l'avez dit que que
nous connaissions mais il est important
que justement ces choses soient dites et
remises
au président de la République et à son
garde des sceaux
j'ai plusieurs questions alors je
reviendrai pas sur l'informatique c'est
un des sujets pour lequel nous
interpellons la Chancellerie depuis
depuis longtemps je réserve ma question
lors du pour le débat que nous aurons
sur les états généraux de la justice
dans notre hémicycle mais d'abord je
voulais savoir comment avait été reçu
votre rapport justement et si des
engagements avaient été pris de prendre
en charge
réellement vos préconisations ensuite
alors un sujet qui pourrait un détail
pour vous mais qui pour nous dans
l'Yonne veut dire beaucoup vous l'aurez
compris la carte judiciaire avez-vous
rencontré les magistrats et les avocats
justement de l'Yonne par rapport à cette
carte puisque si j'ai bien lu le rapport
nous serions rattachés à Dijon enfin ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle ça fait
longtemps qu'on lutte contre se
rattachement mais donc voilà avez-vous
entendu magistrats et avocat du du
département pour cela
vous parlez également de réforme de
justice civile et de plus de
collégialité je pense que c'est
effectivement une très bonne chose
est-ce que dans cette collégialité est
envisagée le fait de mieux faire
travailler ensemble juge aux affaires
familiales et juges des enfants qui
parfois peuvent mettre quatre mois pour
se passer un dossier alors qu'on sait
bien que justement au niveau d'un
divorce conflictuel les enfants ne sont
pas enfin sont des victimes très de ce
qui peut se passer et d'ailleurs à
propos de victimes de violences
intrafamiliales puisque si on parle de
choses qui se passent mal dans le couple
je n'ai pas du tout vu une réflexion sur
ce sujet alors probablement n'était-elle
pas dans vos lettres de mission alors
que pourtant j'ai cru comprendre que ça
faisait partie de
d'une grande cause
du quinquennat passé et du quinquennat
actuel et pour finir puisqu'il faut plus
de moyens avez-vous réfléchi à
introduire du coût plus de magie du plus
de mixité dans la magistrature et quels
moyens pour obtenir plus de mixité dans
la magistrature merci merci Madame
Verrien Monsieur Jean-Pierre Sueur je
propose de prendre ensuite madame
Benbassa et puis monsieur Marc Philippe
dobress on donnera à nos invités la
parole puis on recommencera avec Madame
mariebet madame canaillé monsieur
bonnecarer et Monsieur Leconte
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président
Madame la première présidente monsieur
le procureur général et monsieur le
Président merci pour
ce rapport
qui est très intéressant
c'est vrai que vous avez dit Madame la
première présidente que c'était
révolutionnaire que de ne pas empiler
les réformes
que de ne pas être sectoriel et que il
était aussi tout à fait révolutionnaire
qu'il n'y ait pas 700 amendements 700
articles de plus dans les quatre ou cinq
prochaines années ce qui en quelque
sorte un conseil qui nous est
amicalement donné je voulais poser
quelques questions concrètes d'abord la
première réaction qui a eu lieu à la
suite de la publication de votre rapport
c'était la question des moyens vous
l'avez dit
le garde des sceaux naturellement fera
valoir qu'il y a 8% d'augmentation
depuis trois ans
nous savons que ce n'est pas suffisant
et que la France reste dans les
dernières places au plan européen comme
au plan de l'OCDE par rapport au PIB
pour les budgets attribués à la justice
est-ce que vous avez envisagé des
solutions en particulier ne serait-il
pas raisonnable même si c'est contraire
au principe de la nualité budgétaire
qu'il y ait une sorte de programmation
sur une dizaine d'années pour attraper
le retard avec une sorte de d'injonction
qui s'appliquerait à tous les
gouvernements c'est sans doute un rêve
mais je me permets de l'exprimer
deuxièmement pour ce qui est de la
répartition des magistrats entre le
civil et le pénal j'entends bien ce que
vous avez dit quelle solution concrète
envisagez-vous pour qu'il y ait
davantage de magistrats civilistes
est-ce que vous imaginez des systèmes
qui affecteraient des posts qui feraient
qu'il y aurait une politique
volontariste dans ce domaine
troisièmement vous avez dit Monsieur le
Procureur général que la réforme de la
du Tribunal départemental criminel avait
été faite dans une certaine
précipitation c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
attendu la fin de l'expérimentation pour
généraliser ce système
quel avenir voyez-vous à ce dispositif
êtes-vous toujours partisan je crois
l'avoir lu dans le rapport du jury
populaire ce en quoi vous rejoindriez
monsieur le garde des sceaux à l'époque
où il n'était pas garde des sceaux
un autre point sur la surpopulation
pénitentiaire que vous venez de parler
ce que vous n'aidez vous avez parlé
d'une régulation
quid comment ça se passe concrètement la
régulation et sans abuser j'avais une
dernière question
dans mon département il y a une maison
de la justice et du droit qui traite à
peu près
personne qui viennent par an avec des
vidéos qu'on fait un dévites des visios
qui vont dans tous les chefs-lieux de
canton c'est géré par une greffière qui
est absolument épuisée par l'ampleur du
travail pensez-vous qu'il y a un avenir
pour ce genre de structure je vous
remercie monsieur Sueur madame Esther
Benbassa
merci monsieur le Président je remercie
les intervenants pour leur
intervention synthétique et claire et je
voudrais
toutefois poser quelques questions
dans le rapport vous préconisez de
développer davantage le recours aux
travaux d'intérêt général en effet et
cela permet une réponse pénale plus
claire plus efficace et moins coûteuse
cela remplit une fonction de réparation
et de réinsertion c'est une véritable
alternative à l'incarcération en ce sens
y a-t-il un projet de collaboration à
grande échelle entre les entreprises et
les structures d'accueil et le SPIP une
deuxième question le coût moyen d'une
année de prison
pour une personne détenue est estimée et
il me semble à 32000 euros tandis que le
coût moyen annuel d'une mesure en milieu
et de 10
000 et 2014 euros il est nécessaire
alors de recourir à des alternatives à
la détention et qui de plus
allégerait considérablement le budget de
la justice comment mettre donc en place
et concrètement ces mesures et quand
est-ce que la France va rompre avec la
logique du tout car c'est là
la loi de finances pour 2022 à louer aux
alternatives à l'incarcération un budget
stagnant à
39,8 millions d'euros compte près d'un
milliards d'euros d'investissement
immobilier pénitentiaire ne trouvez-vous
pas qu'il y a un manque d'ambition ou du
moins une répartition inégale du budget
de la justice je vous remercie merci
pour terminer cette première série de
questions monsieur Marc Philippe de
Bresse merci monsieur le Président oui
j'ai une question générale de méthode et
une question plus ciblée peut-être pour
le procureur général Mollens qui
concerne la procédure pénale la première
de méthode c'est c'est de vous avez tous
parlé de réforme systémique c'est de
constater que il y a une réforme
systémique à l'étude pour la justice
mais qui en même temps
pour reprendre l'expression
présidentielle une réforme systémique de
l'intérieur et la police qui se produit
il y a une locmi qui est en train d'être
présentée cette Love Me devrait faire
passer devrait augmenter de 25% en 5 ans
les moyens du ministère de l'Intérieur
et évidemment vous disiez avez fait un
sidament allusion évidemment que dans
cette loop me il y a des choses qui
concernent directement la justice en
particulier la procédure pénale puisque
il y a une réforme de la police
judiciaire une réforme générale de la
police nationale la création d'assistant
d'enquête à une modification du statut
des OPG bref
la question de méthode est la suivante
est-ce que vous pensez pas qu'il serait
utile c'est bien elle s'adresse ça peut
être à Monsieur sauvé que que le comité
généraux des états généraux de la
justice rencontrent un comité
d'orientation du bobo de la sécurité
pour essayer de faire une réforme
systémique ensemble enfin c'est une
question naïve que je pose la deuxième
question est
plus ciblée sur monsieur broker général
Molas qui ne vous a pas échappé que au
mois de juillet de cette année il y a
une jurisprudence d'accord de cassation
qui casse finalement
tous les problématiques qui étaient
liées à la possibilité pour les
procureurs d'aller chercher par exemple
des fadettes en saisissant des
opérateurs téléphoniques sur toute une
série d'infractions et de remontées des
filières de délinquance et que la
législation européenne qui s'impose à la
France
finalement restreint cette possibilité
uniquement à des crimes importants ce
qui fait que les procureurs ont attiré à
plusieurs reprises la conférence des
procureurs notre attention sur le fait
que ils allaient être privés de moyens
très important en termes d'efficacité on
l'avait vu avec ma collègue Agnès
canaillé dans un une législation
précédente et à nouveau puisque nous
nous sommes en train de regarder la loi
Loch me ils attirent notre attention sur
le fait qu'un problème majeur ce qui
suppose ré une réforme soit du statut
euh des magistrats soit de trouver une
solution autre par exemple les JLD qui
semble pas être la solution
satisfaisante est-ce que vous avez une
idée sur la manière de sortir de ce
piège qui finalement est en train de
restreindre considérablement le champ
d'action de nos procureurs à un moment
on a besoin de lutter contre la grande
délinquance merci monsieur
le Président je vous laisse le soin de
répartir éventuellement la parole
merci monsieur le Président
pour les questions de Madame Berria la
mise en œuvre du rapport du Comité des
États généraux un comble au gouvernement
sous le contrôle du Parlement
[Musique]
la mise en oeuvre la mise en œuvre du
rapport du Comité des États généraux un
comble au gouvernement aux gardes des
sceaux sous le contrôle du Parlement
si vous voulez le comité des États
généraux ne va pas urgurer des pouvoirs
qui ne lui appartiennent pas
et maintenant enfin notre mission s'est
terminée le 8 juillet lorsque nous
présentons le rapport et en réalité elle
s'est terminée le 30 avril lorsque nous
avons achevé la rédaction de ce document
on se concerne la carte judiciaire je ne
répondrai pas précisément à la question
qui a été posée sur le rattachement des
juridictions du département de l'Yonne à
la cour d'appel de Dijon où à la cour
d'appel de Bourges mais j'ai compris que
notre rapport avait été compris
je voudrais dire fondamentalement que
nous ne proposons pas de fusion
autoritaire de juridiction ni en premier
instance ni en appel et c'est ça je
dirais le la dimension fondamentale de
notre rapport nous ne considérons pas
que le salut de la justice puisse
résulter
d'une
d'une apparente rationalisation de la
carte en ce qui concerne les rapports
entre le juge aux affaires familiales et
le juge des enfants nous sommes
extrêmement
conscients de la nécessité
de surmonter des
obstacles incompréhensibles à la
communication ça tient à la surcharge
des magistrats à la surcharge des
greffes et à l'incommunicabilité entre
les systèmes d'information
quand on sait d'ailleurs aussi que ne
communique pas le système enfin du
bureau d'ordre pénal d'une part et le
système de l'application des peines
d'autre part
on se rend compte que la gestion de la
justice est aujourd'hui une tâche
quasiment impossible si on n'a pas une
multitude de petites fiches cartonnées à
droite et à gauche qu'on arrive plus ou
moins à classer dans son bureau en ce
qui concerne les moyens et notamment les
moyens humains je n'ai pas bien compris
la question de la mixité je pense que
la question de la mixité ne se pose pas
dans l'institution judiciaire
elle se pose peut-être de manière de
manière inversée mais le Comité ne
recommande pas de numérus clausus pour
garantir
je dirais l'entrée dans la magistrature
d'hommes
qui serait moins qualifiés moins
méritant que les femmes
voilà donc il faut certainement qui est
un équilibre mais contiennent compte
d'abord du mérite
comment oui monsieur présent je suis pas
certain que c'était que la mixité
homme femme c'était une mixité sociale à
cet égard une proposition d'intégration
et ça en était très favorable je le dis
pour la pour la profession d'avocat
c'est qu'effectivement ont déjà il y a
déjà une forme de mixité c'est à dire
qu'on s'aperçoit que
un taux important de magistrat compose
la magistrature sans avoir été sans
avoir sans être passé par l'école
nationale administrature la moitié m'a
dit Madame à Reims et puis il y a des
propositions qui sont faites d'ailleurs
on en parle avec le garde des sceaux
pour fluidifier effectivement là
notamment avec la profession d'avocats
l'intégration
pour répondre à madame la sénatrice j'ai
le sentiment quand même que au niveau du
recrutement en tout cas les codes à
l'administrature la mixité sociale si
c'est de ça dont vous vouliez parler par
exemple était semble-t-il et semble-t-il
assuré comme elle l'est dans toutes les
situation du droit si c'est de et des
profils aussi puisque je viens
d'indiquer il y a des d'autres
professionnels du droit qui intègrent la
magistrature tout au long de la tout au
long de la de
la vie des palais de justice
qui vous permettez là-dessus le comité a
proposé une réforme de la composition de
la commission d'avancement de mémoire
avec effectivement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui elle est composée que de
magistrats
une composition rénovée avec des
magistrats et des noms magistrats
pourraient peut-être effectivement
contribuer à diversifier le les
intégrations ça c'est quelque chose qui
est un problème qui se posera
nécessairement puisque à partir du
moment ministère a annoncé plus 1500
magistrats sur cinq ans ces gens-là il
va falloir les recruter par l'école bien
sûr mais nécessairement par
l'intégration parce que les possibilités
on peut pas pousser les murs à l'ENM à
Bordeaux donc il y aura forcément des
recrutements dans le cadre de carrière
plus courtes à la commission
d'avancement d'où l'intérêt
effectivement d'avoir une commission
rénovée et qui statut suivant des
procédures rénovées pour plus
d'efficacité dans la mixité et dans les
délais d'instruction
merci j'en viens aux questions
de
du président sueur en ce qui concerne
les moyens additionnels dans la justice
doit être dotée
le comité
de manière tout à fait consciente et
délibérée
s'est inscrit dans une perspective
quinquennale et non pas décennale avec
les renforts que nous proposons nous
estimons qu'il est possible de doter
donc la justice de ces renforts dans un
délai de 5 ans c'est extrêmement
ambitieux à tous les étages y compris à
celui des procédures de recrutement la
commission d'avancement l'école de la
magistrature mais il nous semble
important que l'effort indispensable qui
doit être fait pour la justice puisse
être réalisé dans un délai de 5 ans en
ce qui concerne les solutions pour avoir
plus de magistrats civilistes il faut
alors là qu'on s'inscrive dans une
gestion prévisionnelle des effectifs que
l'institution définit ce que sont ces
besoins à moyen terme et que ensuite
effectivement les carrières soient
gérées dans cette perspective nous ne
pouvons pas enfin là je vais un peu
au-delà du rapport et je m'aventure et
je m'expose aux objections de mes
collègues mais nous ne pouvons pas avoir
une gestion qui est uniquement
statutaire de la magistrature il faut
tenir compte des compétences et il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes que ce
soit dans l'administration ou dans la
justice aspire précisément à s'inscrire
dans des parcours de carrière qui soit
définie à l'avance qui soit un peu
prévus il faut qu'il y ait de la
mobilité il faut qu'il y ait de
l'adaptation bien sûr mais je pense que
ce dispositif là est à notre portée il
vaut d'ailleurs pour la justice civile
strictosensus comme pour la justice
économique c'est un point dont nous
n'avons pas parlé dans nos exposés
liminaires mais dont nous avons délibéré
entre nous et qu'on retrouve dans le
rapport il faut créer
dès le début de la carrière une filière
de magistrat qui soit compétent en
matière économique de telle sorte que
les décisions de la justice ne puissent
pas être critiquée ou disqualifier sur
le thème mais ces personnes là ne
connaissent pas ce type de sujet ce qui
implique ce qui implique d'avoir des
affectations internes mais aussi même
externes à l'institution judiciaire qui
tiennent compte de la volonté d'acquérir
des compétences
sur la régulation de la population
carcérale il y a une question d'accord
je vous laisserai la parole pour la
régulation de la population carcérale
pas de numerus closus mais la définition
par établissement d'un seuil de
criticité et lorsque ce seuil de
criticité est atteint on met en place on
devrait mettre en place de manière
préventive des mesures de gestion de la
population pénitentiaire de telle sorte
que on puisse avoir notamment des
libérations conditionnelles mais voilà
il
ne faut pas qu'on ait des seuils qu'on
constate mécaniquement il faut qu'il y
ait une gestion prévisionnelle pour que
des sorties puissent être anticipées
l'important étant non pas de faire enfin
le risque c'est la sortie sèche en fin
de peine sans aucune la perspective de
reclassement et d'accompagnement c'est
ça aujourd'hui le vrai danger de la
justice c'est pas que des personnes
puissent avoir une libération
conditionnelle 15 jours ou 30 jours plus
tôt enfin sur les maisons de la justice
et du droit quel avenir c'est la grande
question ce sont effectivement les
parents pauvres et avec le renforcement
des moyens qui qui est proposé on doit
pouvoir
avoir des greffiers des greffiers en
chef en nombre suffisant avec des
qualifications nécessaires pour tenir
ses postes car aujourd'hui je le
reconnais avec accablement la situation
n'est pas du tout satisfaisante madame
la première présidente et Monsieur le
Procureur général d'une question sur le
tribunal départemental
et peut-être sur l'accès aux droits il y
a 20 ans l'accès aux droits
dans les maisons de justice c'est
vraiment une politique nationale du
ministère de la Justice comme il y a eu
d'autres priorités comme
les victimes les violences faites aux
femmes et que le budget est contraint la
juridictionnelle également l'accès aux
droits est devenu un peu le parent
pauvre des politiques publiques du
ministère de la Justice et je pense que
je peux le dire pour les membres du
comité l'accès aux droits c'est un une
prévention de de
en même temps de l'accès à la
citoyenneté c'est à dire que quand les
citoyens ont accès aux Maisons de
Justice ont accès à un certain nombre
d'informations consultation juridiques
gratuites ça pallie ensuite un certain
nombre de difficultés dans dans la
société en matière civile la question
est complexe parce qu'il n'y a pas que
l'institution judiciaire qui est
concernée par la désaffection dans les
fonctions civiles il y a le ministère de
l'Éducation il y a l'école nationale de
la magistrature il y a le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et ce que
proposer le rapport de l'Inspection
générale de la justice auquel
malheureusement le Parlement n'a pas
accès c'est qu'il faudrait mettre autour
d'une table et l'éducation nationale et
le ministère de la Justice le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature pour
profiler des postes donc la réponse ne
peut pas venir que de l'institution
judiciaire mais suppose une réponse
globale
le tribunal criminel départemental est
donné de connexion tribunal criminel
départemental bon bien sûr que je
reconnais les la valeur de d'une grande
assise à 15 jury populaire mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi raisonner en terme
d'efficacité et on ne peut pas accepter
moi je faisais pas acceptable aussi bien
en regard de l'auteur que de la victime
qu'une affaire criminelle nécessite
trois hommes pour être audencer devant
une juridiction alors que des gens
attendent constatent sur des choses qui
sont importantes donc je pense que le
tribunal criminel départemental pour moi
il se justifie au moins pour deux
raisons la première c'est de renforcer
l'efficacité de réduire les délais de
jugement et la seconde c'est de lutter
contre ces phénomènes de
correctionnalisation notamment souvent
en matière d'infraction sexuelle qu'on
assiste souvent dénoncé simplement ce
que je regrette et ce que j'ai voulu
dire tout à l'heure c'est que il était
prévu je parle très librement je
respecte tout à fait les les choix de
des assemblées j'ai pas de de
jugement apporter là-dessus mais ce qui
est dommageable c'est que alors qu'il y
avait une période d'expérimentation qui
était prévue avec une évaluation qui
serait venue au terme on aurait
peut-être pu voir effectivement de façon
plus précise les gammes
procurés par cette nouvelle procédure ne
le sait pas et aujourd'hui je sais qu'il
y a des départements dans lesquels
effectivement c'est un vrai gain de
passer devant un tribunal criminel
départemental dont d'autres le gars en
termes de délai est beaucoup plus
discutable voilà simplement donc je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faudra
nécessairement prendre le temps d'une
évaluation objective et approfondie des
gains et des inconvénients de cette
nouvelle procédure que encore une fois
dont je vois tout à fait les avantages
les données de connexion
le problème ça fait ça fait cinq ans
qu'il est posé monsieur le sénateur ça
fait cinq ans que la Cour de justice
déjà à travers la race verygueux qui
doit remonter à 2017-2018 qui a été
confirmé à trois ou quatre reprises à
poser le problème de l'interdiction de
la conservation généralisée de connexion
et réglementer l'accès en réservant
l'accès des données de connexion soit
une autorité indépendante soit à un
magistrat en réalité indépendant à
l'égard de la direction de l'enquête je
pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui plus aucun
espoir que ça change il y a eu encore
hier il y a un communiqué de l'accord de
justice là-dessus un arrêt qui est
intervenu à la suite d'une question
préjudiciaire posée par la Cour de
cassation on avait encore un petit
espoir parce que il y avait une
directive qui visait à réprimer les abus
de marché et qui pourrait primer les
abus de marché permettait l'accès aux
données de connexion et la cju a encore
répondu hier il n'en n'est pas question
la norme qui prime c'est la directive
sur la protection des données
personnelles et tout le reste a une
inférieur donc l'arrêt de la Cour de
cassation que vous évoquez qui a été
rendue de mémoire le 12 ou le 18 juillet
je sais plus très précisément 12 juillet
je trouve que le juge a fait vraiment
tout ce qu'il pouvait dans cette
histoire et que l'arrêt de la Cour en
réalité il se borde façon le juge
français doit faire primauté doit faire
doit assurer la primauté du droit
européen à tirer les conséquences de
cette jurisprudence et effectivement
rappelé ce qui pouvait être fait ce qui
pouvait pas être fait la difficulté à
laquelle on est quand confronté
aujourd'hui c'est que je pense que le
travail fait par le Conseil des accords
de cassation permettent de sauver un
sérum de choses sur le renseignement et
la lutte contre le terrorisme la
difficulté qu'on a c'est que la
criminalité grave autorise des choses
qu'est-ce que c'est la criminalité grave
on doit français c'est pas défini
donc vous avez aujourd'hui des parquets
des parquets généraux qui sont en train
de se plonger dans les abîmes de
réflexion pour savoir est-ce que c'est
les peines qui doivent être inférieurs
aux gars à 5 ans à 7 ans à 10 ans donc
pour résumer je pense que le juge a fait
tout ce qu'il a pu il a dit ce qu'on
pouvait faire ce qu'on pouvait pas faire
il est même allé encore plus loin
puisque il est il a procédé à un examen
j'allais dire très stricte des
conditions de recevabilité des actions
nullité donc pour faire en sorte que le
moins de choses possibles qui soit
frappé de nullité moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la réponse à ce problème
elle ne peut être que législative il y
en a pas d'autres avec toutefois en plus
la conscience nécessaire qui a pas de
réponse miracle parce que si on prend
les l'alternative la première ça serait
de dire il faut donner le
l'accès se fasse sous le contrôle d'un
juge
faudrait donner ça au JLD pour des
millions et des millions de données de
connexion on sait qu'il faudrait quatre
ou cinq cent JLD supplémentaires vous
voyez en paysage institutionnel
aujourd'hui et l'état dans lequel se
trouve la justice avec tout le travail
qu'il a
consacré 500 JLD à faire ça je trouve il
y a peut-être vu un faire aujourd'hui et
la seconde qui peut poser les problèmes
un peu plus politique serait de faire ça
sous l'autorité d'une autorité
indépendante il faudrait que le
politique à ce moment-là il peut y avoir
un petit problème politique qui
consisterait finalement à placer un
magistrat gardien des libertés
individuelle le parquet sous le contrôle
d'une autorité administrative
indépendante donc tout ça c'est des
choix politiques qui dépassent je pense
largement en institution qui a fait
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'elle pouvait
merci je voudrais indiquer aux collègues
qu'il nous reste une toute petite
demi-heure et qu'il y a encore 9
questions donc oui une minute pas plus
pour la question monsieur le Président
oui
simplement pour dire à cet instant que
il n'a jamais été question pour les le
comité de revenir sur la hiérarchie des
normes et sur le droit européen
protecteur de liberté individuelles et
fondamentales que des choses soient
soient bien clairs se débat à n'a pas
n'a pas eu lieu et sur la hiérarchie du
norme et sur la jurisprudence de la Cour
ou de la convention vous ne trouverez
pas dans notre rapport
la nécessité ou la proposition de sortir
plus ou moins de la convention voilà je
voudrais simplement le préciser à ce
stade merci Madame aribet
peut-être
de questions
développer le travail d'intérêt général
il y a déjà une agence du travail
d'intérêt général nous proposons de
développer très substantiellement le
service public de la probation avec
éventuellement une agence du milieu
ouvert c'est un domaine dans lequel
effectivement des progrès importants
peuvent et doivent être accomplis en ce
qui concerne le coût des mesures soyons
clairs on ne peut pas faire dépendre le
la politique de la justice uniquement de
considération économique et financière
il est clair que le milieu fermé 32000
euros par an c'est beaucoup plus
important que 1014 euros par an milieu
ouvert en revanche il faut que les
peines
soient pertinentes au regard des actes
commis qu'elles ne contrarie pas et
qu'elle prépare la réinsertion et
par conséquent à la protection sociale
c'est un point qui est fondamental oui
le comité là-dessus c'est beaucoup
interrogé sur l'efficacité de la loi sur
le bloc Pen est-ce qu'il faut y revenir
pas y revenir en tout cas ce qui est
apparu évident au comité ça serait la
nécessité d'avoir aujourd'hui très vite
une audience d'aménagement des peines
qui suivent l'audience du tribunal
correctionnel tout comme il y a aussi
une piste qui a été approfondie
notamment au niveau du groupe de travail
qui consistait finalement à revoir la
répartition des rôles entre le juge de
l'application des peines et le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation il y a un constat qui est
assez largement partagé que après la loi
de 2019 sur block Pen le juge en réalité
il fait beaucoup de choses qui devraient
pas forcément relever de son office et
qui pourrait tout à fait relever de
l'office du directeur du service
départemental d'insertion improbation
c'est peut-être sur ces deux choses cela
qu'il faudrait peut-être travailler pour
améliorer le dispositif
madame maribet merci Monsieur procure
ces derniers propos font la liaison avec
la question que je voulais poser puisque
je me suis attaché au groupe de travail
thématique sur la probation et
l'insertion et vous avez dit des choses
très importantes présidents sauvées sur
le sens de la peine et le travail
d'insertion nous menons actuellement
avec ma collègue Marie Mercier une
mission d'information sur les spips et
il est très intéressant de noter qu'il y
a une évolution du métier
on est passé finalement d'une culture
assistant social et accompagnement à
l'insertion plutôt à une culture de
mesure de la récidive ou non du coup ces
métiers ont bougé mais pour que
l'écosystème fonctionne
et vous avez parlé d'écosystème il faut
que autour des CP
nous ayons tout un écosystème d'acteurs
de l'insertion et en particulier des
assistants sociaux des psychologues et
vous soulignez dans le rapport la
nécessité d'augmenter le nombre de
psychologues et vous parlez pas beaucoup
de assistances sociaux alors que nous
dans notre mission on s'est bien rendu
compte que il manquait un très souvent
ces effectifs là et la question que
j'aimerais vous poser aussi parce que
vous parlez beaucoup d'augmentation de
d'effectifs nous on s'est rendu compte
qu'en fait il y avait un problème
d'attractivité de ces métiers et de la
capacité à recruter et pas simplement
dans le domaine des CPIP
et de l'accompagnement de ces de ces
évolutions de culture métier donc voilà
la question que je voulais vous poser là
dessus je voudrais aussi faire une
remarque un peu plus générale et avec
une question derrière vous avez dit que
nous n'avions outils statistiques nous
ni outil d'évaluation ni
professionnalisation des ressources
humaines du management des ressources
humaines on ne peut aller que dans votre
le sens de votre constat nous allons
rendre tout à l'heure un rapport mené
par avec trois autres collègues sur
délinquance des mineurs et décrochage
scolaires et l'un des points essentiels
du rapport c'est le manque de fiabilité
statistique et d'évaluation des
politiques publiques qui fait que on
peut raconter tout et n'importe quoi à
partir d'une question qui est posée et
dans le dans les groupes de dans les
dans les rapports que j'ai lu alors
peut-être que j'ai pas tout suffisamment
bien lu mais on y avait pas cet aspect
de collaboration suffisante avec la
recherche et avec la communauté
scientifique
et repenser en fait la formation ça
passe aussi par des observ pouvoir et la
distanciation des scientifiques qui qui
évaluent une politique publique il n'y a
pas de politique publique sans
évaluation je sais qu'en France on n'est
pas très fort pour ça mais quand on
regarde du côté du Canada ou d'autres
pays on sait quand même que c'est un
élément déterminant de l'évolution des
politiques publiques excusez-moi
président j'étais un peu merci
monsieur le Président je vais être assez
rapide effectivement le travail mené par
les États généraux le comité des états
généraux de la justice dans cette
approche systémique et qui associe
l'ensemble des acteurs y compris les
citoyens nous offrent aujourd'hui un
éclairage fort sur la nécessité de
réformer la justice en profondeur moi
face à votre vos constats vos
propositions je me pose une question
simple par quel bout commencer comment
se lancer dans ce chantier comment
prioriser les réformes que vous proposez
et qui rejoignent un certain nombre de
de préconisations déjà que nous avons
faire ici au Sénat d'une première
question ma deuxième question est
beaucoup plus précise c'est sur la
question de la justice prud'homale qui
est vrai qui est une justice qui
concerne nombreux citoyens vous avez
écarté d'entrée de jeu les chevinage qui
était une préconisation que nous avions
faites un autre temps d'expérimentation
pour quelle raison puis la dernière
intervention n'est pas une question mais
un complément de ce que sur les cours
criminels départementales c'est vrai que
nous avons accepté la généralisation en
commission mixte paritaire en
contrepartie d'une évaluation qui est
actuellement menée j'appartiens au
comité avec de nombreux magistrats des
représentants du ministère et notre
comité notre notre confrère pardon le
sénateur benaroche qui rendra son
rapport courant octobre sur l'évaluation
des cours criminels départementales
oui ma question va recouper la première
venant avec exprimer par Madame ganayer
votre rapport votre synthèse et de très
grande qualité vous Annette consciente
et vous avez insisté sur le fait que la
justice avait un problème systémique et
que les choses devaient être vues dans
le long terme nous en sommes tous bien
d'accord monsieur sauvé il y a quelques
minutes à indiquer qu'il appartenait
maintenant au gouvernement sous le
contrôle du Parlement d'apprécier la
suite à donner il n'est pas interdit
quand même de vous demander un conseil
entre la grande réforme systémique de
long terme
que vous nous recommandez vivement
mettons en mesure bien que c'est un
chantier de Titan et dont on pourrait
imaginer qu'on finisse par ne jamais la
voir et des réformes sectorielles il va
bien falloir commencer quelque part et
donc ma demande de conseil c'est tout
simplement de vous demander de nous
expliciter un petit peu si vous
l'acceptez la suite de votre travail
entre la logique globale la logique
sectorielle il suit par où commencer
merci merci Monsieur bonnecarère
monsieur Lecomte qui sera oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Procureur général vous avez évoqué lors
de votre intervention liminaire la
croissance de du code de procédure
pénale croissance qui nous a été aussi
largement reproché comme législateur
lorsque nous nous déplaçons dans les
juridictions
semble que les trois causes de cette
inflation sont d'une part le besoin
parfois de réformer deuxièmement les
lois d'émotion et troisièmement la prise
en compte des exigences liées à des
engagements conventionnels
je vous remercie aussi d'avoir lors de
vos exposés diminaires marquez votre
attachement à la hiérarchie des normes
et en particulier au droit européen et
qui nous conduit de temps en temps à
devoir complexifier le code de procédure
pénale pour tenir compte d'un certain
nombre de d'observations alors ma
question est simple quelle est la quel
conseil donnerez-vous au législateur
pour essayer de contenir cette inflation
alors que parfois
nous devons voter des modifications
est-ce que et comment faire pour éviter
finalement de de faire croire de la
croissance de cette de de cette
inflation du code de procédure pénale
lié au aux lois d'émotion
merci Monsieur Lecomte monsieur à la
Richard
Président
je suis
saisi d'une interrogation devant la
première phrase du premier paragraphe du
rapport
qui énonce que le nombre d'affaires
alors que il me semble y avoir tout de
même de nombreux symptômes de
l'intensification de la demande de
litige dans notre société et je voudrais
suggérer sans être déplacé que on
pourrait l'évaluer tout simplement au
volume d'activité
mesurable par un chiffre d'affaires des
professions du droit qui est en net
croissance
il me semble donc qu'il y a une poussée
sous-jacente au moins de la complexité
ou de l'intensité de la plus forte
conflictualité des affaires qui explique
très largement la situation de
saturation de la justice il me semble
donc il faut être au clair sur le
diagnostic et j'ai un doute
personnellement sur le caractère mesuré
et comment dire
optimale Le Mans réformiste des
propositions de création d'emplois alors
que il me semble évident que les
effectifs et le volume d'activité des
professions extérieures qui produisent
de la demande l'activité judiciaire est
exponentielle il me semble donc qu'il y
a un peu un complément de recherche à
faire sur ce diagnostic qui déclenche
ensuite les différentes recommandations
je crois qu'il faut une appréciation
systémique de la demande de
de traitement de litige et je voudrais
ensuite aller simplement dans le sens
des préconisations du rapport dans le
sens où les moyens supplémentaires
devront être gérés il y a un management
judiciaire ce qui est encore un vilain
mot pour une partie de la communauté
judiciaire et ceci devrait se traduire
par une autre mixité qui est que y
compris les fonctions de management
humain
ou matériel d'ailleurs qui reviennent
aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel au chef de
cours devrait donner lieu à une
assistance de nature plus
professionnelle il me semble que on ne
peut pas demander raisonnablement au
chef de cours qui sont déjà très
largement
saturés de jouer pleinement le rôle
d'administrateur de leur juridiction
sans une assistance beaucoup plus
professionnelle
merci Monsieur Richard madame Boyer
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai une question qui courte et simple
monsieur le Président est-ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser qu'elle est pour
vous le calendrier idéal
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons et la quantité de place de
prison à construire d'une part et
d'autre part pourriez-vous préciser
votre pensée s'il vous plaît sur
l'exécution des courtes peines
oui monsieur le Président messieurs
pour mettre occupé de pendant 25 ans de
lieu j de Lille avec le professeur
Jean-Jacques ten je me suis rendu compte
pendant toutes ces années que les
étudiants des zones populaires telles
que des zones comme le Nord
s'autocensurer dans le passage des
concours
à savoir que
très souvent il se disait moins fort que
d'autres enfin ils s'auto censurer
eux-mêmes et c'est bien dommage parce
que un magistrat doit être issu du cru
pour comprendre aussi ce qui se passe au
niveau sociologique et ce qui se passe
au niveau de de
de des possibilités avoir avec les
personnes concernées aussi
alors de ce fait on passe à
l'intégration directe ce qui est tout à
fait bien pour avoir des magistrats qui
comprennent bien sociologiquement et
historiquement ce qui se passe dans dans
la zone concernée mais comme disait
monsieur sauvé tout à l'heure il faut
être sûr que la filière soit
bien établi d'avance et que il n'y ait
pas de concurrence entre les deux
manières d'arriver
à la fonction de magistrat parce que
sinon il y a un délestement de la part
des jeunes en disant de toute façon les
gens plus
âgés plus compétents plus expérimentés
passeront avant moi quelque part alors
moi ma question porte justement sur la
faculté savoir si vous ne pensez pas
qu'il faille intégrer justement la
formation à difficultés
dans
la réforme judiciaire parce que je pense
que si on prenait en charge les
étudiants dès la première année de
faculté on pourrait les guider on
pourrait les former pour être
en adéquation avec les exigences du
concours et la formation par la suite à
l'ENS si on s'y prend trop tard si on
s'y prend en cinquième année
il y a un manque effectivement dans ces
zones populaires de compétences en
matière
de culture générale ou autre et c'est ce
qu'il est gêne considérablement le jour
de l'examen et de et le jour des
concours merci monsieur benaroche
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
juste poser une question intervenir sur
les cours criminels des partenariats
départementales donc je voulais aborder
dans le sens en fait de François Molin
concernant une sorte de petit regret
quand même d'avoir généralisé ces cours
criminels départementales un peu trop
rapidement à notre goût malgré les
demandes qui avaient été faites y
compris par par notre groupe de
prolonger l'expérimentation avant sa
généralisation mais cela étant dit il
est vrai pour compléter ce qu'a dit ma
collègue Agnès canailler qui fait partie
avec moi du comité d'évaluation
que ceci s'est accompagné d'une
évaluation qui est en cours et sur cette
question de l'évaluation j'avais d'abord
un regret aussi là aussi malheureusement
elle paraît un peu limitée parce qu'elle
est organisée rapidement avec une
expérimentation en fait
au cours de laquelle forcément quand un
expériment on met en avant les
meilleures équipes donc c'est les
meilleurs magistrats les meilleurs
avocats les plus compétences qui ont le
plus d'expérience avec tous les moyens
donc la petite
remarque a fait entre autres le barreau
c'est que est-ce que ça va se prolonger
une fois l'expérimentation terminée
lorsqu'on sera vraiment en phase
d'applications réelles et une petite
question au fait que je voulais poser à
François Molins mais il me semble pas
que nous ayons eu des éléments sur en
particulier le fait que c'est CCD arrivé
à éviter en tout cas pendant la phase
actuelle d'expérimentation
la correctionnalisation là vous avez
parlé qui est quand même des deux
moteurs de la mise en place de CCD donc
que pense-t-il de cet élément là et
a-t-il sur ce sujet à certains éléments
à nous fournir
merci Monsieur benaroche c'était la
dernière question il me reste sur le
président apporter quelques réponses je
laisse la première présidente et le
procureur général réponde un certain
nombre de questions et je ferai la
voiture balai
et la question de monsieur le sénateur
Alain Richard le nombre d'affaires est
stable mais on voit que dans les
professions judiciaires il y a une nette
augmentation de des chiffres d'affaires
la question pour les juridictions c'est
qu'elles ont un nombre d'affaires
numériquesment
importantes très
un stock extrêmement important c'est à
dire que c'est pas les mêmes avocats qui
plaident devant les juridictions et qui
représente ce chiffre d'affaires
important si déjà les juridictions
n'avaient pas assez contentieux entre
guillemets de masse je pense que ça
serait moins compliqué et d'un autre
côté on l'a dit les affaires se
complexifient et donc c'est cette double
contrainte je parle de la matière civile
qui a comme conséquence qu'en dépit
d'une certaine diminution des affaires
civiles les stocks
ce qu'on peut dire également au même
moment lié à une ce qui est tout à fait
normal à une jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel le rôle du juge des
libertés civiles c'est fortement accru
il est juge des libertés concernant tout
le contentieux de la contention donc les
c'est une question qui a été posée
augmenter le nombre de juges des
libertés mais ça veut dire augmenter le
nombre de greffiers par rapport au
départage prudomal ou par rapport à la
justice prédomale c'est une question
également qui a été posée mais c'est des
choix budgétaires nous ce qu'on a pensé
c'est qu'à périmètre constant il fallait
1500 magistrats en plus si on souhaite
qu'il y ait un échevinage pour les
conseils des prud'hommes combien de
magistrats en plus donc c'est après
c'est une question de de priorité
gouvernementale et une question de
priorité pour le Parlement une des
questions qui a été posée par madame la
sénatrice du Nord du Pas-de-Calais
voilà il y a une réponse c'est les
classes prépa talents il n'en n'existe
pas dans la région de du Nord
Pas-de-Calais mais il y en a quatre qui
ont été créés en France dans différentes
régions il y en a d'autres qui sont en
cours de création et c'est pour des
étudiants extrêmement méritantes qui
sont boursiers et ça leur permet pendant
un an de préparer le concours oui ça
existe doué ça leur préparé de ça leur
permet de préparer le concours de la
magistrature il y a un taux de réussite
de 25%. c'est aussi une façon de
répondre à la question de la mixité et
c'est classe en fait sont en
déploiement au sein de la magistrature
je commencerai par la dernière question
de monsieur le sénateur sur les corps
criminels départementales je suis un peu
gêné pour vous répondre précisément moi
j'ai appris avec beaucoup d'intérêt que
il y aura une évaluation rendue par donc
cette commission au mois d'octobre et je
pense effectivement que ça servira à
répondre précisément à la question que
vous posez parce que il faut pour
s'intéresser il faut qu'il y ait un gain
dans effectivement la rapidité de et
l'efficacité du traitement de ces
dossiers je répondrai peut-être plus
précisément sur la question sur
l'inflation législative on a dans le
cadre du comité je vais pas vous servir
les statistiques qu'on a récoltées mais
pour donner une idée de l'inflation sur
l'année 2020 loi est décréée en modifié
le code pénal ou texte le droit pénal 34
textes dont 11 lois et sur la procédure
pénale 60 textes dont 11 lois c'est des
sources de la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces donc le
constat il est là je pense qu'il est
facilement partager moi j'aurais
sûrement pas l'autre cuit danse de
donner des conseils au Sénat sur la
façon de légiférer j'irai pas dans ce
domaine là simplement je voudrais faire
trois réflexions qui me paraissent
frappé du coin du bon sens
la première c'est que il y a trop de
normes sur le plan pénal je rappelle
qu'il y a je sais pas si c'est 16000 ou
17000 natts en n'utilise pas le quart de
ces incriminations dans la pratique
judiciaire
seconde chose je pense qu'il faut
arrêter avec ce qu'on appelle la fait
diversisation du droit pénal et les lois
d'émotion je vois pas ce que ça peut
apporter de bon et ça en apporterament
la troisième observation que je ferai
c'est que et sous le contrôle de
quelqu'un qui connaît beaucoup mieux le
sujet que moi il faut progresser dans la
qualité des études d'impact il y a des
études d'impact qui sont très bien
faites il y en a d'autres où la qualité
je suis désolé de le dire n'est pas au
rendez-vous
et ça ne peut que préjudicié
effectivement au moyen nécessaire à la
mise en oeuvre de ces textes et en plus
c'est extrêmement mauvais politiquement
en termes d'effet parce que finalement
on veut un texte qui au bout du compte
ne sera pas ou mal appliqué et la
dernière chose que je voudrais indiquer
et qui est souligné dans le rapport qui
participe de cette vision globale et
systémique c'est qu'il faut absolument
que le ministère arrive à dégager une
véritable synergie dans le mode de
travail entre les directions normatives
et les directions métiers parce que
c'est un des enseignements de ce rapport
c'est que on est dans la situation où on
est parce qu'on n'a pas eu suffisamment
de vision globale et systémique dans la
mise en œuvre des réformes que vous
aviez votées
merci
oui le mot de la fin écoutez la première
fois que j'ai assisté à une audition au
Sénat c'était il y a 41 ans le président
de la commission des lois était monsieur
léon-jo Marignier le Garde des Sceaux
Robert ballintter Robert baninter
annonce son programme Lévis statique en
disant il faut faire peu de lois mais de
bonnes lois et nous sommes au premier
étage là où siège la commission des lois
et je vois tous les sénateurs opinés et
aujourd'hui je dirais à votre commission
chiche
faisons-le le deuxième souvenir il est
dans le bureau du garde des sceaux
toujours Robert Badinter on est en 1983
il y a pas tout à fait 40 ans et
le député Alain Richard dit au garde des
sceaux à propos du milieu ouvert il
faudrait sortir de l'incantation
et avoir
un véritable service public de la
probation alors j'ai été très très
choquée très déstabilisé parce qu'il
disait mais je dois avouer que le député
Alain Richard avait raison alors
maintenant ayant dit cela j'ai dit
l'essentiel pour les spips il y a un
problème d'attractivité il y a un
problème de métier dans ce secteur mais
aussi pour toute la fonction publique et
il y a la chaudière si on veut il y a un
ministre de la Fonction publique le
garde des sceaux on doit repenser
métiers des carrières de la fonction
publique il faut bien sûr qu'il y ait
des outils d'évaluation et qui est une
inscription une articulation entre le
travail des services publics et la
recherche en ce qui concerne la justice
prud'hommage nous n'avons pas proposé
les chinales généralisées mais nous nous
faisons une proposition qui je crois est
tout à fait importante sur la
proposition du groupe de travail
combrexel il faut admission orienter les
affaires soit vers la formation
paritaire s'il y a des chances
raisonnables que la formation paritaire
débouche sur un accord soit vers la
médiation la conciliation lorsqu'une
conciliation peut déboucher mais aussi
aller tout de suite vers le départage
lorsque on sait très bien qu'on ne peut
pas déboucher et ça il faut le vraiment
le mettre le maître en œuvre je pense
que évidemment je fais l'impasse sur
beaucoup de choses il faut je pense
qu'on arrive à articuler réforme globale
et réformes sectorielles comme le
sénateur bonne Carrère la rappeler par
où commencer je vais dire il suffit de
prendre chacune des grandes
articulations du rapport moi je pense
que la direction des services
judiciaires et là sa feuille de route en
ce qui concerne la GRH il y a le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature il
s'acquitte de ses obligations mais ça ne
suffit pas ça ne suffit pas pour qu'il y
ait une bonne gestion des ressources
humaines il faut que le secrétariat
général du ministère de la Justice aussi
prennent en main notamment la question
du numérique bon pour la direction des
sièges judiciaires il y a la répartition
des moyens par juridiction j'ai été
vice-président du Conseil d'État comme
vous le savez mais j'ai réparti de lait
juridictions les moyens en fonction de
la demande de justice c'est à notre
portée on peut le faire et je peux vous
dire que ça contribue à rétablir le
moral des troupes quand on sait que les
ressources vont là où il y a des besoins
et puis
quelques remarques sur les créations
d'emplois je crois que les créations
d'emplois peuvent être suffisantes
même si aujourd'hui on le sait bien le
retard de la justice est imputable à la
complexité des affaires et à la
conflictualité des procédures mais il ne
faut pas aligner les moyens de la
justice mécaniquement sur le
développement de l'activité des
professionnels du droit les
professionnels du droit bien sûr
participent pleinement aux procédures
judiciaires mais en même temps on sait
qu'il règle et qu'il contribuent à
régler de nombreux litiges avant que on
ne saisisse le ministère de la Justice
encore une fois il faut achever les
programmes de construction pénitentiaire
tel qu'ils ont été proposés et pour le
surplus développé les courte peines les
courtes peines d'emprisonnement voilà
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
sur un mot sur l'inflation législative
la proportion de proposition de loi par
rapport à la proportion de projets de
loi est absolument révélatrice et montre
à l'évidence que les parlementaires ne
sont pas les plus prolixes dans la
matière en revanche je dois dire que
l'aspect étude d'impact est un sujet
qu'on a soulevant relevé ici sur la
nécessité d'avoir de véritables études
d'impact et pas tout et parfois éviter
quand même d'impact de qualité moyenne
mais je m'en tiendrai qu'à ce propos ou
à se qualificatif en tous les cas
peut-être que vous dire reprend la
parole j'ai commis un lapsus il ne faut
pas développer des courtes peines
d'emprisonnement donc il faut les
réduire mais chacun avait rectifié merci
il me reste la Commission à vous
remercier à vous monsieur le Président
mais la première présidente monsieur le
procureur général monsieur le Président
du CNB de votre présence ce matin et de
la qualité de nos échanges merci à vous